in our series a more perfect union we
aim to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us this morning how a non-profit
hair salon is helping interracial
families who have difficulty styling
their kids hair Elaine Quijano of our
streaming service at CBS n went to the
Chicago suburb of Oak Park to see how
something as simple as braiding hair can
bring communities together
Elaine good morning I can't wait for the
story yes good morning well as many
parents know sometimes fixing your
little ones hair can be a challenge but
when you're a new mom with a child of a
different race whose hair requires a
vastly different routine than you've
ever known it can be overwhelming and
isolating that's where a rare salon
outside of Chicago is stepping up
helping parents navigate questions about
hair and a lot more cornrows will make
her hair last longer and then she can be
as athletic as she wants to be
Linda Bulger and her mom Vanessa have
been regular visitors to the salon for
years it was apparent right from the
beginning that her hair was different
than mine and that what I had been used
to in my life up to that point and so I
knew that we needed to get some
education Vanessa
adopted Linda when she was three years
old and I went to a lot of salons
nobody does children's here the moms do
it well it's like I can't I don't have
that skill I don't have that knowledge
as a newly adoptive mother what was that
like for you when you would get told
well we don't really have the ability to
help you and there was a new Tears
I was literally in tears I did not know
where to turn through a chance
connection they met to make a swim the
salon owner who was just beginning to
steer her career into a non-profit
mission I realized how much leg that
there was from the african-american
community to help and I know the salon
environment as a stylist and how
sometimes it can feel like you're being
judged but she said that is why I felt
honored to be part
the challenge into something different
that would be non-judgmental that would
be open and loving thirteen years later
the conversations have gone well beyond
hair care at styles for kids
uncomfortable questions are answered
openly fights should I say black or
african-american I mean as simple as
that because I didn't want to insult
anyone I didn't want to be insensitive
to anyone swen helps parents understand
why some African Americans might be
opposed to interracial adoptions are
they really exposing them to what is
going to help them succeed in life as an
African American person I think that's
like the main concern the parents have
formed their own community where they
can share tips and help their children
interact with people who look like them
it's so important for that child to know
I am African American and although I
grew up in a family that didn't look
like me that I am owning Who I am as a
person
lessons Linda Bulger is embracing coming
here and getting my hair that makes me
happier makes me feel more confident and
when I walk out I feel like I can
conquer and just one sign of success for
Swint I have a depth to my life and
friends that I wouldn't I have had if I
was on that path so I'm grateful
I felt really grateful that I loved her
she's never out of my life I told her
that earlier and you are never out of my
life
it's been such a blessing the
friendships that I formed with the moms
and dads I'm sorry there's nothing like
it
jamika started styles for kids nine
years ago with just three clients whose
hair she would style in their homes
today she has her own salon and has
helped hundreds of families across five
states
she says this is just the beginning wow
I love everything about this story a I
love Vanessa wanting to learn
I love Tamika recognizing that there's a
need because I do believe we're all more
alike than we are different but there
are differences when it comes to black
hair and white hair and that is
undeniable hair matters really she's
bridge builder because this is about
creating a place where people can ask
questions without fear of being judged
and that's not a you know a place that
many people feel comfortable at Elaine
thank you so much
you